ABOUT THE TIMING AND CONTEXT
ABOUT WHAT THEY CALL A VERY
UNUSUAL EMAIL.
TOP DEMOCRAT ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE WILL WORK
WITH THE FBI TO EDIT HIS
REBUTTAL TO THE REPUBLICAN MEMO
RELEASED LAST WEEK ON ALLEGED
BIAS BY THE BUREAU AND THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT, TWO WEEKS
AGO NOW.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS HE WILL NOT
DECLASSIFY THE ADAM SCHIFF
DOCUMENT BECAUSE IT CONTAINS TOO
MANY OF THE COUNTRY SECRETS.
HERE IS CATHERINE HERRIDGE.
>> THOSE THINGS NEED TO BE
REDACTED.
>> HOUSE REPUBLICANS BACKED THE
WHITE HOUSE REJECTION OF THE
DEMOCRAT MEMO THAT THEY SAY IS
LOADED WITH NATIONAL SECURITY
SOURCES.
>> HIGHLY PLACED INTELLIGENCE
ASSET ATTENDED AN EVENT AT A
PARTICULAR TIME.
I CAN FIGURE OUT WHO THAT IS.
>> SOURCE CLOSE SAYS DEMOCRATS
CAN EXPEDITE THE REVIEW BY
MAKING THE REACTIONS LAID OUT IN
THE LETTERS SIGNED BY FBI
DIRECTOR CHRISTOPHER WRAY AND
DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
NO COMMITTEE VOTE WOULD BE
REQUIRED AND THE MEMO COULD GO
DIRECTLY TO THE PRESIDENT FOR
DECLASSIFICATION.
THE STORE SAID REVISIONS BEYOND
THE RECOMMENDED REDUCTIONS WOULD
LIKELY REQUIRE ANOTHER COMMITTEE
VOTE BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
RANKING DEMOCRATS SEEMED OPEN TO
CHANGES.
>> WE ARE GOING TO SIT DOWN WITH
THE FBI AND GO THROUGH CONCERNS.
LEGITIMATE CONCERNS, WE WILL
REDACT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP ACCUSED